Green Chemistry's role in sustainability.
So we already talked about the definition of sustainability.
I have to confess,
I like,
um,
the way I kind of paraphrase it,
preserving what you can't live without and preserving it forever.
Okay.
So sustainability is a century's long perspective.
The decisions you make are not short term.
It's not about the next financial quarter.
It's a,
it's not about the next election cycle.
It's about centuries,
decades and centuries.
So if you are resource planner and you were planning in 1914,
what 2014 needed to look like,
you would make sure that you had enough,
well,
oil for lighting,
you would make sure that you had enough wood for fuel.
It's certainly want to have enough rock software,
refrigeration and you're better beef up on the horses for transportation because
those horseless carriage things.
And now we're going to take off,
okay,
what actually happened?
These are the charts where the land use to feed horses peaked at 89 million
acres a to less than 3 million in 1961 when they stopped keeping the records
because it was irrelevant and useless.
This is w,
uh,
would you use this fueled?
Um,
these are all from department of Commerce went from a high of 5 billion cubic
feet in 1900 to less than 500 million acres in 1970 when they stopped keeping
the records because they weren't crucial to the economy.
So when you,
there was this great New York Times article,
I believe it was in 1896 the talked about the,
um,
the increase in horses for transportation in Manhattan and they projected the
increase in population and therefore the increase in horses to transport people
in the increase in the natural byproduct of horses on the streets of New York.
And they projected that in just a few years,
the average height of that natural byproduct was going to be taller than the
average person.
So what happened?
Oh,
this is at a time when the environmental technology was a bucket and a shovel.
Okay.
So what happened?
Did they ban horses?
No.
Technology intervene to change the equation.
A change,
the trajectory that we run,
he can argue about whether or not cars were the,
uh,
and,
and a trolley cars and things like that with the best long term solution.
But Science and technology intervene to change that unsustainable trajectory.
So we start looking at the great challenges of sustainability.
Everybody can have their own list,
but certainly,
um,
population has to be up there,
right?
So we're talking that,
uh,
let's see,
since Iran,
when I was,
I was born,
we're more than doubled the population.
We went from 3 billion to over seven.
Okay.
Uh,
and the past,
uh,
when I was 60 years,
we tripled the population.
And where is that population growth happening?
These are the richest nations of the world.
These are the poorest nations of the world.
Okay,
great.
So that tells us that what we have to do is increase the state of development of
the poorest nations in the world.
That will bring about higher quality of life,
higher state of development,
higher learning follows,
uh,
almost always follows I,
or empowerment and education of women.
And you bring about a stable population growth.
What's the problem with that?
Problem with that is that historically coupled with
increased of state of development has been increased resource depletion,
environmental degradation.
All right?
So the challenge becomes how do you increase the state of development,
the quality of life while reducing the detrimental effects,
the detrimental effects of uh,
uh,
of this economic growth,
avoiding the resource depletion.
Last I checked and that's exactly what Green Chemistry and green engineering is
all about.
How you decrease the,
the adverse consequences,
the hazard,
the toxicity,
the pollution while getting higher performance.
That's what we're going to be talking about this whole semester is how do we
manifest this?
This is not going to be theory.
We're going to be seeing countless examples of how we're achieving exactly that.
So what we want to do is get a,
the higher state of development and do this kind of leapfrog technology and
we're going to talk a lot about leapfrogs and I'm going to want all of you to
know about some of the leapfrog examples.
Okay?
Um,
this is one of my favorite of all of a president Kennedy's quads,
that the great enemy of the truth is very often not the lie,
deliberate,
contrived and dishonest,
but the myth persistent,
persuasive and realistic.
So there's a mythology that you can't have economic development,
you can't have growth.
You kind of have increase in jobs.
You can have,
uh,
increased quality of life unless you're going to essentially destroy the
environment,
use toxic substances.
Green Chemistry is belying that myth every day.
I'm going to talk to you a little bit about some of these.
So let's talk about
energy.
Everybody knows in this room knows that the vast majority of our energy,
uh,
in the world today is generated from nonrenewable sources.
Um,
all right,
so this is the projected increase in consumption of energy over time.
These are the projections and this
is what is projected to be the portfolio of energy.
Still oil,
still natural gas.
It's still cold.
What Green Chemistry and green engineering sustainable design is all about,
is changing that trajectory,
changing that balance,
so that though that is not inevitable.
All right.
So it's looking at developing alternatives for energy,
uh,
generation,
everything from photovoltaics,
hydrogen generation fuel cells,
biobased uh,
in addition to these alternative energy sources that we're going to talk a lot
about.
It's also about,
uh,
Catalin [inaudible].
We're going to talk about [inaudible] and how you can undertake transformations,
for instance,
of one material into another with dramatically lower energy with dramatically
lower waist,
with dramatically lower material consumption,
global change.
All right.
I hate the phrase global warming.
Um,
I,
I sometimes use the phrase climatic chaos because what's happening is when we're
adding energy into what's largely a closed system,
um,
and when you do that,
some places will get warmer,
some places will get colder,
some places will get wet,
or some places will get dryer.
It's not about this,
this linear,
uh,
progression.
It's about how you add turbulence into,
uh,
into a system.
And the literal definition of the word chaos.
This is one of the classic,
uh,
pieces of,
of data.
Uh,
the,
this shows the temperature change over the past thousand years.
This shows the increases in carbon dioxide concentrations over the last several
years.
Um,
and these are the initiatives over time.
Okay.
All right.
So I'm telling you this quick story.
One of the most powerful,
um,
greenhouse gasses is not,
there's not CO2,
but a lot of the CFCs,
the floral conference and many of these were,
uh,
were used as fire extinguishing agents.
Okay.
This is an example of a technology it's called pirate piratical of a fire
extinguishing agent
that didn't use EFCs,
completely eliminated CFCs.
Um,
and so no emissions.
It basically served to make water a more effective fire extinguishing agent by
using surfactants in a formulation.
Okay?
So why do I tell you that?
Because he in such a big deal of fire extinguishing agents and they contribute,
even though there are about 24,000 times more potent a greenhouse gas,
then CO2,
no,
that's not why I'm telling you until you this.
Because one,
he can use the science and technology of this technology to use and other
applications.
More importantly,
when this fire extinguishing agent was used in a,
uh,
and an oil tanker player on the Bosphorus Straits,
Lloyd's of London,
uh,
estimated that this would take,
10 days to put out in this fire extinguishing agent,
put it out in 12 and a half minutes.
So what does that mean?
Come back to JFK?
The great enemy of the truth is very often not the lie,
it's the myth.
The myth is the green products with not go into work as well.
Then if you're going to get an environmental benefit,
if you're not going to have environmental degradation,
you're not going to get the pro form.
It's on the function that you want.
I am going to show you your going to discover your going to research examples
over and over again that are more functional,
higher performance,
and environmentally beneficial and sustainable.
So how do we change the equation?
It's not about just CFCs or,
uh,
all the,
all the like,
how do we make greenhouse gases so that,
that actually,
um,
uh,
functional,
how do we take CO2 and,
and build it into our polymers and plastics?
It's being done.
Brilliant work by,
uh,
a company founded by Professor Jeff Jeff Coulton Codec Cornell,
making new plastics.
She's Co two.
All right,
so we know that we have a resource depletion issue,
uh,
that we've talked about that we know that we were burning a lot of our natural
capital,
a like it's a fire sale.
How do we,
what green chemistry is doing this?
How do we use bio mass?
How do we use a nano science so that we get the,
the function that we want with dramatically less material?
How do we go into carry out transformations with visible light rather than
chemicals and material?
How do we use carbon dioxide as a feed stock rather than as a waste number when
it's a waste,
not a waste,
when it's a value added material.
All a waste is this is a material or energy for what you have not found a
valuable endpoint and titan,
which is a biopolymer or waste utilization.
All right?
We're gonna be wrapping up talking about a food supply.
We actually produce enough food.
There's an equitable distribution.
So there's still regional star starvation,
which is tragic.
But if you take a look at the green revolution that I talked about,
Norman Borlaug,
this is the development since 1960,
the food production absolutely astounding.
Good food production in the developing countries,
uh,
and industrialized nations belt.
You have to ask the question,
how did it happen?
That's part of how it happened.
So how do we get that important performance producing food,
feeding hungry bellies,
but not doing in a way that's,
that's contaminating our drinking water building up in our bodies.
And that's what green chemistry is developing new pesticides,
which are only focused on the target pest and not all of the other beneficial
insects think fertilizer and fruits that fertilize Agilent's the draw the
fertilizers to the roots so that you don't put 10 times the amount of fertilizer
so that you wind up having it going into your drinking water,
but you only put down what is actually going to be taken up by the,
uh,
by the plant methods of using agricultural wastes for beneficial and profitable
uses.
So one of the key areas that we're going to talk about is,
um,
toxics in the environment,
toxics in our body.
And this is one of the great strengths of how you decouple the adverse
consequences of ta of chemicals
from the performance.
Then we talked about,
as you all know,
I'm a chemist,
I love chemistry,
I love chemicals,
I hate hazard,
I hate on sustainability and I ain't going to be the last one that will ever say
we ought to stop using chemicals.
What we need is things that are chemical free.
I find that very silly.
We just discussed that everything's a chemical.
The reason that I've,
and on a personal have devoted my professional life to green chemistry is
because not because I,
I hate chemistry and dislike chemistry.
It's because we can do better that chemistry can do far better.
It's transformed the world and some very positive ways and it's transformed the
world and some very consequential and adverse ways.
And one of the things I know as a person who's been involved in green chemistry
for a lot of years now,
um,
is that we can get the benefits without the adverse consequences.